it's our pleasure to declare that the
main power stadium officially open
[Applause]
mia dan gordon and north canterbury
sport and recreation trust chair don
robinson cut the ribbon today in front
of hundreds of residents
who'd braved the rain and snow to attend
the official opening of the main power
stadium
well it's been a long time in the making
over 20 years i think it means a lot to
our community
to our young athletes to all our sports
people to those that are going to use it
more broadly as a multi-use facility
seeing the numbers here today to me is
evidence
just how much it does mean to the
community and it's a great deal
visitors were able to take tours and
explore the various rooms
including the central fitness centre
main court area and coaching and meeting
spaces
[Music]
inside the main court area local teams
got their first chance to try out the
courts
and put on sport demonstrations for the
guests
yeah it's really good thank you it's
pretty mean yeah
even though i don't play basketball that
much it's actually pretty cool
the building was designed by warren
amani architects and built over the
course of 18 months by lee's
construction
the stadium was completed on time
despite a short delay due to the covert
lockdowns last year
at 6 000 square meters in size and
featuring four standard sized courts the
community facility
is the largest to be constructed in the
district
it will be managed by the north
canterbury sport and recreation trust
who along with local sporting clubs have
been eagerly awaiting the opening of the
stadium
as the district's expanding population
has outgrown available court space
this is a game changer for the community
it's state of the art we've got
everything we could possibly need
and it's leading-edge stuff just look
out there at the number of kids we've
got playing and everything like that and
that's
through our primary school coaching
program we've got a great team
and we're just really excited about the
opportunities and his sentiments seem to
be echoed by the hundreds of happy faces
seen around the stadium today
ensuring that this facility will be a
valued asset for the community for many
years to come